siamo in due
viviamo in un'epoca straordinaria
credo che su questo non ci siano dubbi
da parte di nessuno
con tutte le valenze possibili a
riguardo non solo positive anche
negative ma non solo negativo e anche
positive e c'è un epoca proprio come
quella che stiamo vivendo
proprio qui in questo momento dove molti
tempi confluiscono e molti spazi
molti i tempi perché c'è una tale
varietà di influenze di concezioni idee
del mondo revisioni del vivere il
convivere umano molto diverse tra di
loro e provenienti da ambiti anche a
loro volta molto antichi così come al
tempo stesso lo spazio abbiamo come
l'impressione che si stia restringendo
ma del resto è così da un certo punto di
vista abbiamo molte più comunicazioni
riusciamo a incontrarci a scontrarci
molto più rapidamente
la cosa interessante come musicista è il
fatto che tra tutta questa varietà di
tempi nessuno escluso
come diceva ecc e xp lovecraft il grande
scrittore ci sarà sicuramente anche un
tempo in cui tutti questi tempi si
incontrano
e a volte ho il sospetto che siano
proprio sia proprio l'epoca in cui
viviamo
questa è una grandissima opportunità non
fosse altro che per appunto coglierne
tutte le le possibili non solo
sfaccettature ma le inevitabili
ricchezze in scambio e della musica che
mi ha insegnato praticamente alcune cose
di quelle come queste sulla vita e e
anche su sulla mia stessa esistenza e
sull'esistenza anche degli altri
una cosa che mi ha insegnato prima di
tutto man mano che la prendevo e la
praticavo e che diventerà sempre più
come dire prominente evidente questo
questa esperienza era che mi poneva una
domanda e da dove mi prendi intesa dalla
musica cioè come fai a farmi e questa è
una domanda molto interessante perché se
da un lato l'apprendimento che chiunque
potrebbe fare a partire da qualsiasi
materia di studio e appunto di
apprendimento apprendendo la impara i
modelli con le tradizioni con i
predecessori con i protocolli con le
tecniche e quant'altro nel campo
cosiddetto creativo per eccellenza cioè
quello delle arti così riconosciuto
anche da tutti da tutto il da tutto il
genere umano come un area
particolarmente prediletta a indagare
questo genere di cose finito la parte di
apprendimento semmai essa finisce si
presentava appunto la questione di la
musica che c'è in me può essere
naturalmente di
beethoven può essere di charlie parker
può essere aironi stones così come
chiunque voi vogliate ma se abbiamo un
certo appetito e vogliamo indagare
veramente fino in fondo qualsiasi genere
di fenomeno credo che non ci sia persona
che non si senta e non si trovi spinta
sul ciglio dell'indagine laddove ci si
deve porre una domanda che cos'è
veramente questo e in questo caso la
musica e a che cosa serve naturalmente
c'è una risposta per ognuno di noi e
tutte sono valide al tempo stesso
all'emergere quindi questa domanda
diventano sempre più evidente una cosa
che era lì fin dall'inizio nella mia
esperienza la prima di studente di
apprendista e poi eventualmente di dire
qualcosa di mio
e cioè
musica è una cosa che comunque non è
fatta solo di musica così come del resto
tante altre cose
man mano che sono andato avanti nella
mia evoluzione è diventato
fortunatamente sempre più evidente il
fatto che la musica mi stava insegnando
un qualcosa che poi ritrovavo in un
qualsiasi ambito umano e questa è la
cosa che la rende estremamente attuale
nel modo di cui voglio andare a dire e
cioè allea degli stili che uno possa
fare al di là delle scelte voglio dire
di appartenenza musica classica jazz
rock quello che nel momento in cui
realmente la pratica e la prende e a
quella domanda di da dove vieni e come
faccio a farti dicevo fortunatamente le
due cose si evidenziano appartengono a
qualsiasi ambito dello scibile umano in
qualsiasi ambito di pratica e studio sia
in ambito scientifico che in ambito il
quotidiano e cioè tutto è formato da
composizione e improvvisazione
noi tutti quotidiane quotidianamente
viviamo la dimensione della composizione
era è l'aspetto dell'improvvisazione
io in questo momento per quanto io abbia
traccia di quanto sto dicendo anche con
le l'impasse piacevolmente accettate
comunque ho una parte di composizione e
da una parte di improvvisazione non mi
preoccupo più di tanto del fatto di cosa
sto andando a dire cercando di essere
conveniente secondo determinate regole
di linguaggio condivise che naturalmente
vanno attese se faccio una pausa ancora
più lunga di quella di prima si crea un
un certo stato di pensione sono leggi
musicali o se volete sono leggi che la
musica manifesta in un modo sensibile
come tutte le arti l'architettura pieno
vuoto pittura chiaroscuro musica suoni
pause pause dicevano che composizione e
improvvisazione sono sempre
indissolubilmente intrecciate nella
nostra vita addirittura formano la nea
spa della nostra stessa prima modalità e
dall'antichità da tempi molto antichi
proviene tutto quanto ho imparato di
moderno attualmente nella musica nel
senso che non si tratta solo di
materiali non si tratta solo di musica
non si tratta solo di informazioni non
si tratta solo di studi si tratta
proprio del fatto che improvvisamente è
diventato evidente grazie a questa epoca
che l'antico
estremamente moderno e a riguardo la
questione che sensibilmente mi si pone
grazie sempre anche al passaggio di
testimoni che ho ricevuto da maestri ai
quali naturalmente mi sono nutrito
abbeverato e quant'altro è il fatto che
in questo mondo così rapido e veloce
non si tratta diventare soltanto
altrettanto veloci ma si tratta di avere
l'opportunità e i mezzi e qui entriamo
la questione della dell'aspetto
autoeducativo che hanno le arti la
musica di poter fornire gli strumenti
per aggiornarci alloggi con tutte le
caratteristiche che già avete
sicuramente condiviso non solo in questi
interventi precedenti ma che sono sugli
scudi tutti i giorni con tutte le sfide
e naturalmente questa comporta
io ho costituito e di questo si tratta
io ho costituito un un organismo che si
chiama wedding era formato da amici
colleghi e studenti dove siamo tutti
musicisti attivi insegnanti pedagogico
pedagogia che dir si voglia in questo
momento niente e nuovi tipi di
imprenditori a riguardo di che cosa
dell'importanza che ha in un mondo così
troppo enfatizzato è spostato su
l'aspetto compositivo previsione
planning se facciamo il gioco dei
sinonimi possiamo stare quasi una
stasera dove nulla di male ma quello che
manca a controbilanciare l'aspetto
fondamentale è che diventa un elemento
educativo sostanziale è avere dei luoghi
con operatori istruttori educatori che
dove si possa esercitare per forgiare
generazioni equilibrate l'arte
dell'improvvisazione
dovevo bindra questo è il nome
dell'organizzazione
che ho costituito promuove la creazione
di questi luoghi e lo studio e la
pratica dell'improvvisazione finalizzata
a tutti non solo a chi si interessa di
aspetti scienze gli aspetti di scienze
umanistiche
se così si può dire gli aspetti
artistici e lo scopo principale di due
bing è quello di promuovere un disegno
di legge a livello mondiale e portare
all'attenzione l'importanza
dell'improvvisazione come l'elemento
innovativo nella formazione degli
individui in programmi scolastici che ne
prevedano lo studio al fianco di tutte
le altre materie già esistenti dalla più
tenera età fino alla formazione adulta
dell'età adulta per chiunque
naturalmente si è interessato a questa
visione del futuro dove
l'improvvisazione è tutta una materia di
indagine per ognuno di noi andare a
vedere da dove viene e che storia abbia
avuto nel andare e venire delle umane
vicende nella storia dell'umanità
naturalmente abbiamo un sito che web
indra punto org l'intenzione appunto e
quella che vi ho detto e adesso
concludendo vorrei naturalmente dare
luogo se voi mi consentite a quello che
io ritengo oggi per ed avergli offerto
in termini si la divisione di futuro che
è un futuro antichissimo riguardo
all'improvvisazione ed il futuro è ora
andando a completare questo intervento
con una parte di improvvisazione che
naturalmente vede realizzarsi
questo che per me oggi è stato un
concerto per parole idee musica la
musica è in noi e in voi
la musica è qui proprio qui ora è la
musica e anche lì ora
grazie alfredo ponissi gabriele accuso
grazie a tutti